welcome back time for the fastest seven
first up we could all be hearing this
catchphrase again
you're fired you're fired you're fired
you're fired
you're fired you're fired president
trump reportedly mulling an apprentice
reboot
asking aides questions like how would
you like to see the apprentice come back
and
remember the apprentice greg what do you
make of this
uh this is uh oh look okay this came
from the daily beast which is two levels
below
the weekly world news i've never met a
person
who's working that used to work at the
daily beast because they never get
another job
so this is bs he's not gonna do a tv
show he's gonna do a network you don't
go from the most interesting president
ever to hosting a game show
but in theory and i'm just spitballing
here
jesse that could be part of a network
right i mean people loved him on that
show
i'm going to pretend that i'm going to
believe in this show
i think it could be great just for the
sake of argument like you could even
have a fox edition you could have
hegseth
competing with dobbs and janine and
i would watch and right now i think his
last season
you know he had about 11 million an
episode he started off with about almost
30 million an episode how many people
voted for
what 74 million people you get a
fraction of that and you're the number
one show on television
so there's an appetite for it and i'd
watch for sure now
now do network yeah
i don't want to compete against let's be
real here
talking about one shot dana
i think that he will be a very
interesting former president to watch
he is got a ton of energy got a lot of
drive
he's got a big following he can the
hardest thing
for him is going to figure out what
things does he most want to do because
anything he wants to do he's going to be
able to do it
juan you'd watch it i know you would
i don't know who would hear it but i i
mean i it's not my cup of tea i didn't
watch the original
but i will say that if he's if he's
asking this question
i think there's some good news there
implicit he's now acknowledging that he
lost the election so i think there's
something in there
also i you know when i think about him
going back like that
i just think you know most other former
presidents
they move on to charity work maybe he
should talk about taking the vaccine
himself something like that
yeah obama went on to charity work at
netflix right he's uh
all that money is going to charity yeah
yeah 100 million something like that
yeah the book deal all of that next up
more drama on the set of the movie
mission impossible
seven five crew members are calling it
quits after this viral ramp from star
tom cruise following about following
covid's safety rules we are not shutting
this
movie down is it understood
if i see it again you're going
and now the actor is reportedly taking
an early christmas break
from the filming of the movie i
think that's real dana because tom
cruise is
not that good of an actor he's never
done a good movie
maybe all the right moves but no way
it sounds like he needs a break so maybe
that's good like to ever take a break
we're all getting a little break
we get a little break calm down be all
right
jessie i shoot this into my veins stegan
i love it
i want to be it i'm actually thinking
about having more emotional outbursts
like this and i don't even care if the
producers record it
leak it all you want it's good buzz for
the five
should i do it we'll do it live
we'll do it live
one not that one
gosh i you know for me look it it's uh
it's it's cold it's dark and
we're going through a tough time with
the virus but you know there's light at
the end of the tunnel and we can get
away
from having to listen to tom cruise's
you know going off
and making people uncomfortable he may
be right you know we have to keep our
distance but
i think a lot of people just think boy
that's an ego out of control
greg you know i think he's going through
a very stressful period and i think you
know there's a book out there that could
really help him
i think it's called dianetics and uh he
should just pick it up sit down and read
it
and you know might help i thought you
were going to say the plus
i was going to say the plus i was you
knew but i thought
no i'll just go with dianetics get his
thetas
are they go get his fetus get his
beatens
instead of watching any uh tom cruise
movies maybe watch
leah remini and mike rinder's show
that's on netflix about
that scientology